as they went to the polling stations
voters in Fiji echoed the concerns of so
many others around the world the cost of
living crisis and rebuilding the economy
after the covid-19 shutdown this
government is doing so much for the
people they are giving bus fares food
vouchers even the lot of things the
government has done people are just
really
nervous about how things are going to
turn out and excited also for the
possibility of change
that nervousness was because the
election was largely a choice between
two men with a history of interfering in
the Democratic process prime minister
Frank bini marama led a military coup in
2006 and has been in power ever since as
with the previous vote in 2018 his main
Challenger was another former military
man citiveni rambuka who led two coups
in 1987 before being democratically
elected as prime minister given the
collective history of the two there's
been plenty of apprehension in Fiji
about what could happen after this vote
I accepted my defeat in 1999.
congratulated Mr Chowdhury I'd say the
uh uh president's house and office and I
hope we can do that
we cannot live forever we cannot rule
forever as Barney marama went to cast
his vote in the capital Suva he was in
no mood to discuss with the media
whether he would respect the outcome I
haven't got any intelligent report from
Australia to come and ask me questions
better questions than
thank you this year Fiji found itself at
the center of a geopolitical tussle
between China and the United States and
its allies Australia and New Zealand
while Fiji chaired the Pacific Islands
Forum Beijing launched a diplomatic
offensive attempting to sign a regional
security and economic pact with Pacific
countries which was unsuccessful
any military intervention after this
election would again test Regional
relations and potentially add to the
economic concerns of fijians
Wayne Haye Al Jazeera